it's important to keep an eye on joe
biden's policy proposals because on the
one hand you have donald trump holding
huge rallies as if there's no pandemic
while insulting joe biden saying joe
biden is stupid as he did earlier this
week
and then on the other hand as a con
contrast you have joe biden actually
proposing some pretty interesting
policies and one such policy that joe
biden
recently released is a 10 tax penalty
on companies that move operations
overseas and then on the other side of
that
a 10 tax credit for companies that
create jobs
in the united states i like the idea
of joe biden rolling out more economic
policies because
if you're someone who's voting on the
big picture right you
you realize donald trump is a completely
incompetent
systemic threat to the united states and
the world and he's made the country a
global laughing stock
you may already be clear on i'm voting
biden in november
there are people who for one reason or
another
need some more specific economic
justifications to vote for joe biden
and one of those is that joe biden says
he will reverse some of the worst
policies of the trump administration
which he believes are
loopholes that allow offshoring to take
place
despite donald trump claiming his entire
campaign
and during his presidency that he would
be and has been great for the american
worker
and for american business it's
impossible to ignore
the reality that joe biden on some of
these issues
is saying he will achieve the exact same
thing donald trump promised to achieve
when he was campaigning
which is joe biden much like donald
trump said in 2015
says he will revive american
manufacturing joe biden
much like donald trump campaigned on in
2016 says he will create more american
jobs and
bring some supply chains back to the
united states of course
you will notice that the reason joe
biden is saying he will do those same
things is donald trump
promised to do them but failed to do so
and joe biden's new proposal
will target offshore profits now and
then this is going to
bigger picture get added into his plan
to require corporations to pay at least
a 15
minimum tax on domestic profits as many
of you know
even though we have a corporate tax rate
here in the united states with no
required minimum tax on corporations the
way individuals have there's something
called the alternative minimum tax
for individuals meaning you can't use
deductions and loopholes
to get down to not owing anything that
in theory that's the point of the
alternative minimum tax
joe biden is proposing something similar
for corporations
on the other side of this is you've got
on one side
a 10 percent tax for offshoring and then
you have a 10
made in america tax credit which you
would qualify for
if you as a business owner revitalize a
closed or almost closed facility
in the united states if you expand a
facility
if you bring some production back to the
united states and there will also be a
ten percent credit available
if you increase manufacturing wages you
it has to be based on pre-coronavirus as
a baseline
up to a hundred thousand dollars this is
super interesting let me give you an
example of how it works
you could conceivably have an employee
earning fifty thousand dollars
and you could say i'm going to give them
a raise to sixty thousand dollars
on that ten thousand dollar raise
biden's proposal is
the government will kick you back ten
percent of it so you give a ten thousand
dollar raise
the government gives you a thousand
dollar tax credit so
you give someone ten thousand dollars it
only costs you nine
that's very very interesting and you
know the macro economic impact
needs to be scored uh but conceptually
it's very interesting
now i i wonder how many of you are
waiting to see whether i will do this
i would be a hypocrite if i didn't point
this out
when joe biden says it because i sure as
hell pointed it out when donald trump
said it
all of the talk about bringing
manufacturing jobs back to the united
states
a lot of these jobs are not coming back
period it doesn't matter if donald trump
is president
it doesn't matter if joe biden is
president and you know a 10
credit here a 10 tax there it's not
going to do it
and that is because the united states
made the decision
implicitly decades ago that we are going
in the direction of being more of a
service-based economy more of a creative
economy
and outsourcing manufacturing to places
where it's cheaper
like china that's the reality and that's
a global reality that's
bigger than 10 tax here or 10 credit
there now that being said if this
incentive got american companies
to for example move a call center back
to the united states
that is much more plausible and i would
find super interesting
for for me one of the biggest customer
service nightmares is when you're trying
to deal with something sensitive for
example
banking payroll airline tickets internet
security
and customer service centers are located
in other parts of the country
which is fine other than when you're
dealing with people that
do not speak english at a certain level
of proficiency that really affects
customer service and when you look at
internet service providers that offshore
call centers when you look at airlines
and all of these others consistently
it destroys the customer experience
we've had recent internet problems
our internet service providers tech
support is in another part of the world
run by mediocre english speakers they're
not bad people they're no worse than
americans
but it is not a great customer service
experience at one point the payroll
company we used to have
had customer service overseas it's not a
great experience to be trying to set up
you know the proper tax deductions for
employees and to have someone where you
don't even know if their english
level is at a level of proficiency where
they're getting what you're trying to do
if this idea gets call centers back in
the united states
that would be super interesting and it
would be really good for a lot of
companies
in any case we're going to continue
tracking joe biden's proposals
this is an interesting one meanwhile
donald trump is doing rallies and
calling joe biden stupid
you decide which approach you prefer i
know which one i prefer